But now it just want to give you
some biographical details. Um,
that might be kind of
interesting. Parallel, um, to, um,
the basically the entire body of
work by a Fitzgerald that wears thin.
Um,
last time we were ready assault that
Fitzgerald was married to seldom,
um, psia. Um, and she was a very, um,
um, you know, basically the, the um,
social center in Montgomery,
Alabama where he was stationed.
Um, so, um,
he referred to her as the
first American flapper.
So obviously there has resonances
of for the story, but he's,
Bob's her here,
you know,
we know that that is where he gets
that part of his inspiration for.
Um, and so it, it actually, um,
and he has other stories
about flappers as we know.
Here's the whole collection called
flappers and philosophers. So, um,
seldom has been there pretty much,
um,
from quite early on in the short stories,
but really the work and we're just seldom
has the most important presence is um,
tenderness and Nate,
so just some interesting details,
some interesting parallels.
Some of you might have been surprised
that the call you refers to dig as captain
diver right when she raised
him from the sanitorium.
Um, and in terms it's not really a very
well accounted for because Dick and fat,
um, didn't really fight. Um,
he was considered too
valuable to be lost in battle.
So he was in Switzerland. He
was nodding in combat. Um, but,
um,
Nicole refers to him as captain diver
and it turns out that this is kind of an
interesting personal connection
to Fitzgerald's on live
and this relation to the
seller. It turns out that, um, in the, uh,
Fitzgerald collection that I
was talking about last time, uh,
the University of South Carolina, um,
there are a couple of very price, uh,
of items in that collection.
One is this briefcase, uh,
saying Scott Fitzgerald Fifth Avenue,
um,
and the other is this hip flask,
uh, with an inscription from it.
Um,
and it turns out that this is
a gift from Zelda to Scott.
Before they were married,
when they were just coding.
And this is the inscription on that
flask to first lieutenant as Scott
Fitzgerald, 65th infantry.
Camera's Sheridan, forget me,
not [inaudible], September 18, 1918,
Montgomery, Alabama. So
it turns out that the,
the military rank is a
small personal detail, um,
in the caution the attribution,
um,
often military ran that in fact was not
really the real professional identity
for first year at any point. But,
um, she finally, I mean he was there,
he was in Montgomery, he was not fighting,
uh, either in Montgomery, Alabama,
but,
um,
she referred to him as first attending
more dignify a title and we'll see the
titles as they were the ones referred
to as doctor or mister as they make a
difference. Um, intended. It's
nine. So from the very beginning,
I kind of title consciousness on my part
of Fitzgerald that gets translated into
the captain drop diver in
tender is the night. Um,
but that's just a very,
very small connection.
The most important condition is some
of you might know has to do with a very
long history as long and painful history,
um,
of mental instability
on the part of the cell.
There basically from the 1930s on.
Um,
she never was not inside
clinic at some point, you know,
Hook career until she died.
Um,
she was in and out of mental institutions.
some more luxurious than others.
I'm not looking like Amanda Institution
has also, we'll begin with those. Anyway,
this is their,
um,
referenced to him as Captain
Diver and a tennis tonight. But,
um, this is the one of
the first issue when two,
I think it might've even had been the
first, uh, car praying Gwynn's in, um,
problem in Switzerland. Um, uh,
and we'll see a picture of her room there.
There was in 1930.
Uh,
and as you can see almost like
a hotel room and very, you know,
not looking like a idea of Amanda Mental
Institution and certainly not the place
where Dar would go to when it
goes to Jackson, Mississippi.
So at the very other end
of the social spectrum,
that's where she started out when she
began her long career of medicalization.
Um, and this is, um, her,
the picture of her release from
problems and you can see the,
she actually looks very different
from when she was 18. Um,
the almost unrecognizable the
two of them. Even what, I mean,
I guess it's separated by
a number of years as well,
but really I'm looking very,
very different. Um, and that
was, I think there was the,
the earliest instance in 1930, um, to, um,
even there was a unduly optimistic that
noses that she was recovered as you
recover from, um, the,
the breakdown because she was
very soon hospitalized again.
And this time in and other
even more famous Swiss clinic,
um, the rural Horsley which is where
young actually your practice. Um,
so in an infant I think for,
I was sharing was there briefly as well.
So in tender is the night,
there's a reference to fry that Dick
Divers to get to Vienna before Friday
retires. And there's also, um,
the Swiss clinic. So all that is,
is in part,
um,
it kind of has the connection to sell
us on medical history in Switzerland.
Um, then, and then she went
to a bunch of other ones. Um,
I can't even keep track of all the ones,
different ones that she went to. Uh,
but at some point in 1932, she went
to Johns Hopkins was back in this,
they were back in this country.
She went to Johns Hopkins Hospital and
that turned out to have put an opponent
in fact on both of them because
when she was at Hopkins,
um,
what part of the treatment was there?
She would have to write
for two hours a day.
That was part of the medical treatment.
Um,
so she started writing. She
wrote a novel called, um,
save me the walls, uh, which
was published in 1932. Um,
it was only about a thousand copies,
so,
so it, you know, it didn't make its
way into American literature. Exactly.
Um, but it's interesting in many
ways because it is sell the,
using her own medical history,
using her marriage to a scarf is general,
um,
using all their personal stuff
as material, um, for this,
for this novel.
And Fitzgerald actually tried to stop it
from the impoverish or try to revise it
very significantly, uh,
before it was published. Um,
and then after it was published here,
this opinion about his wives
novel plagiaristic unwise
in every way should not
have been written. Um, so this is a,
in many ways kind of long and
painful example of the many,
many instances in American literature
of the husband having some control over
the wires writing different.
Most famous example is Ted Hughes and
Sylvia Plath rater who lenders were
actually edited by him,
um, after her death. Um,
so in this case she did get it published
but it didn't reach a very wide
audience and he was against
their from day one. Um,
the daughter Scottie had the
similar different opinion.
She just said that this sort of
competition is traditionally the bane of
literary romances.
So at least she has a fairly clear view
about the marriage that there was quite
a bit of competition going on,
even though obviously he was
the one who was the writer.
She has some aspirations as well.
And if she had encouraged my actually
help have had more of a career.
Um, so the element of competition, uh,
between husband and wife I think is quite
an important theme. Even though, um,
Fisher road try to downplay it,
you know,
in saying that his wife is the one who
really had no talent and she had to
plagiarize from him,
um,
that he must've register the fact that
she was more of a competitor than he let
on. So we'll see how that plays
out in the dynamics between, um,
Dick Diver and they call and who winds up.
So there's one other super interesting,
this is actually not so important,
but just the kind of a point of reference.
Um,
as we know, there's another woman,
significant woman in tenders and they,
rosemary the actress. Um, and it
turned out that I think this is,
it's generally thought that this is the
person, um, bad rosemary is based on,
and we can sort of see that,
you know,
she has this very
wholesome in the sun look,
but she also was tremendously
disciplined as an actress. Um,
and in these shared a very
distinguished career as an actress. Um,
so this is the, the, um, the,
the Hollywood contribution
to tender is the night,
but I want to emphasize,
um, and other, um,
today's lecture actually will be
more about cinematic techniques.
So in even though she personifies
Hollywood's contribution to tender is the
night,
um,
Ashley is in terms of formal techniques
that film would have more of an input on
the narrative technique of tenders night.
Um,
but I want to go back very briefly to,
um,
do something that we've been
talking about all semester,
which is the very important,
um, and in many ways, uh,
variously played out dynamics
between the half and half, not, um,
so just,
I know you guys might not have
gone to the and of this novel,
so I apologize for giving you,
but there's really no way I could talk
about the novel without talking about the
ending. Um, so without knowing
the details in between,
this is the last two
paragraphs of tenders tonight.
But he became entangled with a girl who
worked in a grocery store and he also,
he was also involved in the lawsuit
about some medical question.
So he left Lockport after that.
He didn't ask for the children
to be center in America
and then answer when they
call wrote asking him if he needed money
in the last leather she had from him.
He told her that he was
practicing in Geneva, New York,
and she got the impression that he has
saddled down with someone to keep housely
and she looked up at Geneva in an atlas
and found it was in the heart of the
finger lakes section and consider
a pleasant place perhaps.
So she liked the thing, his
career was biding his time. Again,
like grants and Galena.
His latest note,
it was postmarked from corn.
Now New York,
which is some distance from Geneva
in various more time. In any case,
he's almost certainly in that section
of the country in one time after,
in one time or another.
So those last five nurse,
uh,
it's five of the pruners was
in American literature. Um,
he's a total nobody by the animal
novel in one time or another.
Um, so this is a novel that, um,
loose very fast. You know,
we start out with him,
um, at the top of his profession,
full of promise. In fact,
when we first see him, he
is idolized by everyone, um,
around him,
um,
to get from there to this ending that
the woman in his life would be someone
that he sees in the grocery store.
And not even that I'm getting into trouble
of his very modest medical practice,
a drifter, a drifter going
from one small town to another,
and there's the additional in
south that he starts out in Seward,
Switzerland of city that
everyone knows about to Geneva,
New York,
which Nicole has to look up in an atlas
and he can even hold on to this Geneva.
So, um, it is in many ways
the ending is the beginning,
but the highly ionized
beginning. Uh, so just to,
um, we've seen this structure before and
I promise you will see it one more time.
Um, so, um,
the last three novels that we read
basically of this thing structure,
but for totally to
totally different effect.
So from what we've,
no,
at this point we know that there's one
other novel has this circular structure.
The ending is the beginning,
which is for whom the bell tolls.
So we've talked about this, we just
want to give you those two sentences.
Beginning,
he laid flat on the Brown pine near the
floor of the forest and then the last
line he could feel his heart beating
against the pioneer floor of the forest.
Um,
so it is having ways,
very tender rendition of a life that
could be construed as the life of a half
not right.
You know,
we talked about that possibility that
maybe he really has nothing I has is a
broken leg that's very alcoholic. We
then, which is not to be dismissed,
but against that ironic reading, um,
handling where post variable there,
uncle,
um,
image of in the [inaudible]
as the beginning, uh,
as the kind of,
uh,
Adler's deferral of the moment of death.
So he's still alive is almost as
if it were beginning of again,
and we as the readers one
end to begin all over again.
It is that illusion perpetrated in our
minds to me this morning that Hemingway
is able to write a novel that in some
sense doesn't really have an ending.
Right? You know, if the in
the ending is the beginning,
the actual death scene is the
four to the point of infinity.
So this is having ways very tender,
uh,
wrapping up of the life of Robert
Jordan and for whom the bell tolls.
And in contrast to that,
Fitzgerald is about as brutal as can be.
Um,
it's um, so he, you know,
this actually is, um,
kind of surf surprising that,
um,
that he would want to be
so thorough going, um,
in the dental or the vision of the diver.
But that's,
that's he wants how he wants to rate.
Um,
so today we'll look at that ending,
um,
the cruelty of that and
laying that, um, to, um,
the question there is a speed. We know
that the novel was moving very fast.
Lots of things have to happen
for us to get to that very,
very low point at the end of the novel.
So what has happened and what this
Fitzgerald have to do in order to speed up
the narrative to such an extent that he
would get to that absolute low point. So,
um, last time we talked about, um, montage
and we talk about flash back, right.
Um, as to cinematic techniques
that are input into Fitzgerald.
And today we'll look at
three very, very common, uh,
filming techniques and the way that
they actually help to speed up the
narrative.
It is not self evident that a close up
would in fact speed up the narrative.
But the way Fitzgerald uses
his close ups actually does,
and it's not always clear the cross
cutting with speed up the narrative,
one of the scan. And he uses this very
fun techniques to move things forward.
And then we have the very fast
motion of the negatives resolutions,
things being taken away from,
from, um, from Dick Diver of. So,
um, let's look at a couple
of instances of close up. Um,
and this is just so obviously visual
that it's sort of hard to look away from
that without actually with how to read
this without having some kind of visual
image. Um, this is about
rosemary as you know,
she has this crush on
him, on the diver, um,
and really desperately ones, um,
you know, to, to have an affair.
Um, so, but it doesn't quite
happen for, for awhile.
Presently she kissed him several times
in the mouth who face getting big as it
came out to him,
he never seen anything so dazzling
as the quality of the skin.
And since sometimes beauty gives
back to images once best thoughts,
he thought of his responsibility about
Nicole and have the responsibility of her
being two doors down across the
corridor, the reins over. He said,
do you see a sign on the slate?
Rosemary stood up and
leaned down and said,
most sincere thanks to him.
We're such actors,
you and I. Um, so okay, so, you know,
we're starting out and you know
it on one kind of register.
Um, we're starting out
with the notion of, um,
rosemary as this kind of
love stick puppet. Um,
that's just pining for
him. Um, and, and, and,
and unrequited love on top of
that. That is going nowhere. Um,
so and so the first part up to the last,
uh,
three lines of that,
of that passage is really all about
Dick dies in this noble person.
Even though he could have taken advantage
of rosemary and she was pining for him,
he could have easily
taken advantage of hers.
And I doing that because thinking
of his results to Nicole,
two doors down the hall,
all that is really about a nobility
and magnanimity and uprightness of Dick
Diver.
Um,
the last three why's swingers to the
other and of other sides and narrative.
And all of a sudden we see what
kind of a person rosemary is,
that in fact we don't really,
and she was completely truthful.
Rosemary is never not truthful.
Um,
even though she's an actress,
she actually is the most
truthful person in the novel. Um,
and this is an absolute statement that
is completely right about both of them.
She is an actress. Um, so
it's very hard to know where,
um,
you know,
where the acting begins and where
the feeling with the acting and,
and where they're feeling begins.
Um,
she's so discipline that you would act
in a certain way and then she runs into
an obstacle and she stops acting in
that way as she was doing right there.
You know, it's like trying out, you know,
one rude and saying that is going nowhere
and then suddenly seen that maybe you
should act in a different fashion.
Um,
so there is a way in which the emotional
life of rosemary has been completely a
professionalized to such an extent that,
um,
that she's always acting,
which was not even to say that
she's not sincere and, um,
Fitzgerald credit score of being sincere.
It's just that that is what she is.
I don't think that she's capable of
having any kind of emotions outside of her
professional identity as an
actress. Um, so this is, um,
you know, this, this is what she is.
So it is the blindness to that,
that he doesn't realize,
um,
that she's not exactly a lovesick puppy.
She is someone who is actually
acting in a particular fashion.
Um,
and who not only has the
full understanding of what
kind of person she is,
but she is a full understanding
of what he is. Right.
So it's not surprising that she should
know herself to be primarily an address
is not an accusation to say that that's
what she is above everything else.
She was primarily an actress,
so she has that degree of self knowledge,
but she also has the knowledge about
him that even though he is supposedly a
doctor,
he actually is at heart an actor and that
is an accusation and much more serious
accusation directed at him than it is
directed at her because she has been
totally upfront. You know, she's not,
she never, she never is not an actress,
um, from beginning of the novel
too. And she is defined by that. Um,
he is supposed to be a doctor so
he's not supposed to be an actor,
but they turn up,
turns out that maybe the end,
the most truth about him
is that he is an actor.
And then all the,
all the appearance of nobility
or the appearance of uprightness,
my turn out to be an act that is putting
up for her benefit and act that is
putting up for his own benefit.
Sometimes we can act
for ourselves as well.
So it shows the degree of knowledge of
him and it clear eye on the set amount
of,
on off sick evaluation of
exactly what kinds of man he is.
So it is the most acute statement about
Dick Diver that we've seen up to this
point. This is quite
early. Page one oh five.
So it is that acuteness that astute
knowledge about the man that she was
supposedly idolizing that gives the lie
Ashley to the adoration that she seems
to be raining on him.
Um,
that is actually completely within bangs.
She was practicing,
you know, what if, what it's like
to be an enduring love puppy,
she's acting that pot,
but it's a pot that she is
just doing it very well.
Um,
so the,
just to move this to the two
analysis of the narrative technique,
um, the moment, um, that, um,
that, that when we have that kind
of sudden switch in perspective,
um,
Ashley comes with um,
a visual detail that her face is coming
closer and closer to him and a face is
getting big as it comes up to him.
So let's remember that one visual detail
that her face completely fills his
field of vision that he
sees nothing but her face.
So let's keep that one visual detail in
mind and see what Fitzgerald does with
that detail that close up. So this
is another scene quite a bit later.
Um,
Ashley's a flashback.
So going back to the point when they call,
we're still in the sanitorium when she
was asking him to take care of her,
Nicole was up in her
head now crew or school,
trying to collate the center mentalities
of a childhood as deliberate as a man
getting drunk after battle.
He breathed over her shoulder
and turn her insistently about.
She kissed him several times.
Her face getting the,
every time he came close her hands,
holding him by the shoulders,
Israeli hot.
Suddenly there was a booming from
the wise loves across the lake.
Cannons were shooting and have bearing
clouds in order to break them of help,
bearing clouds knowledge to break them.
The lies of the prom and not
went off went on again. Um,
so the,
we get that the repetition of
that same visual detail, um,
they're kissing her face,
getting very big as it gets close to him.
So the repetition of the same clothes
out and we'll this odd is that we get
exactly the same narrative sequence.
After that close up,
after their visual detail
of the fares getting big,
we get the sacs switch
to a different narrative.
Register, right? So
this is not Nicole, uh,
passing judgment on him.
So it was not exactly the same
structure as the incident with Rosemary,
but there's a switch abrupt switch to a
different sequence of narrative in this
case is such a quite a
trivial event. Um, there were,
there were shooting cannons in order
to break up the hell bearing clouds,
I guess is something he do in Switzerland.
Um,
but the point is that
cannons were being fired,
right? Um, in peace time in Switzerland,
which is the kind of surprising fact in
itself since when those not so familiar
with Canada's being
fired for that purpose,
but given the fact that we'll
be seeing the intertwined,
the superman pose, um,
images of love and war,
the firing of the cannons is
certainly not trivial at this point.
So at the very least,
we can say that there's an
intrusion into this scene of
the undeniable and historical
proven reality of war as well.
One is just a fact of history
that there was such a war.
So this is visceral,
is not going to recreate that war
for us except for the going over the
battleground and talking about it ticking,
you know,
20 lies to events of foot that
referenced and we saw last time,
he's not going to go further in the
direction of whirlwind and he has done so
far,
but he is going to give us echoes of Whoa,
Whoa. One in civilian
situations. And not only that,
but he's going to use that as a narrative
follow up to love scene specifically
to close up when a woman's face
is getting bigger and bigger.
So we can say that what the close
up is doing for Fitzgerald is,
especially the woman's face getting
bigger and bigger is the dramatization of
visualization of the woman's
power goes with demand, right.
So when Rosemary,
his face is getting so bad that she
stills the entire visual tableau,
that is the point when we
see that Rosemary Ashley
knows exactly what comes from
and the driver is that she is
absolutely clear that about him. Um,
here there's not that equivalent cleared.
I judgment from the pilot and they
call because she's still a patient.
She hasn't gotten to that point yet.
But Fisher is giving us equivalent the
structure equivalent of that kind of
judgment in the sense that there's a
sudden break up of the love scene and the
replacement of that love scene by
something that is like an intimation of
battle.
So at the very least,
we should be prepared for the fact that
maybe war is not extraneous to laugh,
maybe more is actually organic to love
that maybe Warren is the narrative
structure of love.
That love takes the form of a battle
between the two people who are turning
joined in this fashion.
Um, so this is, um,
in many ways a kind of a prelude
to a kind of visual tableau,
um, that is, uh, a kind of a gesture
towards the future of that narrative.
Um, but I want to look at
another technique now, um,
which is also very prominent
and very unmistakable, um,
in, uh, tenderness tonight, which
is determining of crosscutting.
Um, so this is in book two
of a tangent is tonight.
And especially in section
10 of 10 of Bach too.
So the beginning of session 10
begins where in Zurich, in September,
Dr Diver had tea with baby Warren.
So at this point still a doctor,
um,
and is in that professional capacity
that he would have tea where baby Lauren
and sister who's trying to get a doctor
to take care of her by a doctor from
their call.
Um,
so they're having tea and talking
about various things and he's still not
agreeing to being alive lawn care
taker for Nicole at this point. Um,
but this is what happens on page one 58,
one page done. Next page actually. Um,
we get a southern abrupt
switch to Nicole's point of
view from her point of view
and narrated by Nicole herself
as in the first person. Um,
so let's see. This is
outside of her exchange. Um,
the ladders there, she
wrote rise to dig, die for.
We'll get a sense of how Nicco
things by following this, um,
this, this kind of monologue
that is given to us. Um,
as counterpoint to the TB train,
Dick Diver and, and, and baby Warren.
How do you do lawyer?
We're going to call tomorrow for
a week and then back to Zurich.
That's why I want you in system to settle
this because it doesn't matter to us
how much I'm allowed.
We're going to live very quietly in Syria
for two years and Dick has enough to
take care of us. No baby. I'm
more practical than you think.
It's only for clothes and
things. I'll need it. Why?
That's more than than the estate.
Can they stay really afford to give me
all that I know will never managed to
spend it. Do you have that much? Why
do you have, why do you have more?
Is it because I'm supposed
to be incompetent? Alright.
Let my share pilot them. No,
they refuse to have anything.
Whatever to do with it.
I have to feel bloated for us.
I'm not even reading and very well at
this could in and read much better. Um,
to get the tone. Exactly.
What a sharp business woman,
Nicole.
Yes.
In the space of one short exchange.
She achieves through things she
manages to get her share of the estate,
right. So you know, she only
needs, it begins by saying, okay,
we're going to live very modestly on
the next page. We don't need the money.
I just needed for clothes and you know,
incidentals. So very modders requirement,
very modest demand on the estate.
She gets the amount,
she says it's too much.
She checks out to see how much baby is
getting and finds, I'll you. In fact,
what she's getting is
less than what baby gets.
So she gets an increase right
then and there on the spot.
More than that,
this of course the question whether they
will have a share of that income and
she's admitting to the fact that she
would have to feel below that for the two
of them, that he's not going to
get a penny of that any home.
So in the space of one paragraph,
that switch from the exploded view to
Nicole's point of view is in fact an
incredible fast forward of the narrative.
Changing our conception of Nicole from
a patient in a mental institution to
sharp business woman who
is going to keep very,
very tight control over the
money that comes to her,
um,
that we shouldn't forget after all,
she is the granddaughter of a man,
um,
who has a huge fortune who has made
that huge fortune and there's a constant
reference as an, uh, for whom
the bell tolls, the length,
the cross generation linked
to the grandfather, um,
in tenders the night this also across
generation cross-generational link to
Nicole's when father that maybe she is
more her grandfather's granddaughter than
we may think.
So the effect of that cross cutting is
to take the narrative away from the x
side of the story and
deposit the Asian saves.
Strictly on Nicole side, the, she is the
one who's asked, they call them the shops.
She is the one who actually has to
financial control over the future of that
marriage. Um, so it, it, it,
let me just give you one other,
um, much more smaller incidents
of that cross cutting. Um,
all of this many pages after that cross
cutting his toe in the first person in
the Co's voice.
Um,
and so from being a mental institutions
and there's just married to, to,
to, to take diverse are there the saddle,
she has the control over the money.
Um,
but she also is beginning to complain
about the particular shape the marriage is
taking.
But I was gone again by that time
trains and Beiges they were all one.
That was why he told me a traveling.
But after my second child,
my level go topsy was born,
everything got dark again.
If I could get word to my
husband who has seen fit to the,
certainly here to leave me
in the hairs of incompetence.
You tell me my baby is black.
That's farcical.
That's very cheap.
We ran to Africa merely to see 10 God.
Since my principle interest
in life is archeology,
I'm tired knowing nothing and
being reminded of it all the time.
So page one 61,
um,
we can see the speed of this development
of that particular orientation of the
marriage from the beginning when she's
not even married to Dick Diver to the
next page one 59 when
she's married to him.
But retaining full control of her
finances to page one 61 when she is in a
position to complain about
his behavior as a husband.
Uh, well there's art here and the thing
is actually quite have a handle on the
[inaudible] is that once again,
this was with two of those completely
in explicable intrusion of a racialized
detail.
Um,
and the person of Nicole's
daughter tops it, um,
that my baby is black is really coming
out of nowhere except for the fact that
we know that Fitzgerald has a long history
of racializing particular characters
or critical moment.
So let's just go and you guys know
the tops is a reference to, um,
uncle Tom's cabin right into Harriet
Beecher. Stowe is novel. Um, and um,
Tufts is a black character and it's one
of the most vivid black hairdressers in
that novel.
So his fist gyros kind of backhand
attributed to 19th century classic.
And resurrecting the name
of a black character, um,
totally inappropriate names
for the dollar of Nicole,
but nonetheless, that's
what he just give her. Um,
so this is just to just to flesh
out the features of the history of
racialization, um, in
Fitzgerald and the great Gatsby.
We know that there really are no
black characters in the great Gatsby,
but there's this constant intrusion
of black hairdressers strangely.
So as we cross Blackwell's island limo,
same pastors driven by way show for
and which that three mothers knee,
two bucks an hour ago, I laugh,
allow us the yolks of the eyeballs,
rope to others in holiday rivalry. So
this is gas. We go into town with, uh,
nick and all of a sudden the intrusion
of the three blacks in the Limo Syndrome
by wedge show for that is a
kind of a visual metaphor, uh,
for the upstart guest be trying to,
um,
to elevate themselves higher
than he, than he should be. Um,
in this case it, the
racialization, um, that,
that we see in tender is the night,
um,
has to do I think with a
Mormon of marital volatility.
Um,
we know that she actually has control
of the basic structural future of that
marriage, which is the money. Um, and the
given that control,
she is in a position to put a particular
spin on that marriage and the marriage
has to do with Nicolette,
with the fact that they are
traveling because he is,
he needs to travel,
that she has an involuntary appendage,
um, to his constant travel and
um, the, his neglecting her.
So this is in many ways a very early
paving of the ground for the eventual
outcome of the novel that is highlighted
by Nicole presenting herself as the
victim. Nice party in the marriage. Right?
So to racialize herself and to racialize,
her daughter is a very specific and I
guess tested technique of demonstration,
a degree of grievance.
The degree of felt oppression of the pod,
even though she's not really black,
is almost as if she were the
black person at that rate.
So that's what the metaphor is doing
for her. She's anything but black.
But she's treated as if she were black.
That's what she's claiming.
So we don't really know with,
we agree with her. Yeah.
But this is who Nikos interpretation
of the marriage is that she is the
oppressed party in that marriage.
Um,
so let's look at one other
instance of crosscutting to Nicole.
And this is once again taking the
narrative agency or at least taking those,
landing the story on Nicole
side to why don't you,
why don't you register,
register and why did you register mister
and Mrs diver instead of doctor and
this is diver. I just wonder it
just throw it through my mind.
You're taught me that work is everything.
And I believe you used to say a man
knows things and when he stops knowing
things,
he is like anybody else.
And the thing is to get power
before he stops knowing things.
If you want to turn topsy turvy or right,
but most you are Nicole follow
you walking on her hands.
Um,
so I think that by page one 60 to one
page for the shape of what is to come is
pretty much unmistakable
and it is conveyed very much
through a tome of voice,
um, through, in this case,
almost a repetition of exactly the same
kind of structure that we're seeing
between dead and rosemary.
Rosemary is the one who am page one
oh five already has seen true take the
heifer.
She has thin through him so that he or
she can pass the most wounding judgment
on the Houston. Now the
doctor isn't afterward. Um,
Nicole has arrived at that
conclusion on page one 62 that he,
he's not a doctor or a doctor as opposed
to know to have medical knowledge.
That's what makes a medical
doctor another good after his dad.
Here's more knowledge than his patient,
but she knows at this point that in fact
he doesn't have any more knowledge than
the average person. They just
lost his claim to being a doctor.
And so,
you know,
they're not that many more identities
available to him once it's lost that claim
to a professional identity. She's not
saying outright that he's a dog, the,
he's an actor,
but she's implying as much.
And there's that other detail about
his wellbeing turned topsy turvy.
Um,
as well as the naming of the thing that
the thing is to get power before he
starts knowing thing. Um, it is
naming exactly what it is the
deep diver has failed to do.
If he has done things from bright,
he will have had after we can chose
the marriage before he loses out in the
Department of Knowledge.
But now that he's lost out in
the department of knowledge,
he's not going to have power
in that marriage as well.
So the very sharp,
clear,
I absolutely understand the of judgment
of her husband is very much an echo of
what rosemary has test into it
much earlier. Um, and it comes,
it comes over to us,
comes across to it once again through
the technique of cross cutting. So, um,
you know, I was, I would
say that the, so, so the,
the emptying out of any kind of sustenance
anymore of sustenance in Dick divers
come very,
very early and is through this complete
the steady erosion of any emulation,
um, for him on the part of the two
women who started out as great, um,
idolizes of him.
Um,
so now we've gotten to a point where
we actually see the speed of the,
of the negative resolution and picking
up the speed becomes just faster and
faster. Um, so this is the first, um,
the Sousas the couple there three,
basically the three points
of no return for desire for,
on his way to losing his medical
practice and Lockport. Um,
the first point of no return is the
fight he gets with a cabin near Erie.
He walked past the staring a currently
in airy and up to the grinning face,
hit it with a smashing,
left the side of the jaw.
The man dropped her for this
is a cab driver he got into
a fight with for moment.
He stood over him in trials.
But even as the first Pang of doubt
shot through him, the world real,
he was clubbed down and FIS and boots
beat on him in the strange tattoo.
It felt as nose break like a shingle.
And his eyes jerk as they a snap back
on the rubber band into his head or rib
splintered. And those then
pain, he'll voluntarily,
he lost consciousness,
regain it as he was raised
her same position and there's
risk joke together with
him cards.
The plain clothes lieutenant,
whom here knocked out was themselves
drew back his arm as smashing into the
floor. Um, this was a very brutal scene.
Lots of people are getting shot and Duke
diver is important to turn out to point
out this,
not except from that violence.
And this is the first emptying
out of his professional identity,
um,
that he adopted is supposed to be
treating someone who has been subjected to
that kind of violence.
And instead it turns out he is the one
who needs a doctor to take care of him.
Um, so, um,
this is what happens when you have
things happening very fast and this is,
um, um, image. Ashley of the
Caribbean area, which it's still,
it's kind of sinister looking,
but this is the person that gang of
them actually beating up on the guy for.
Um,
so what is interesting is that even
though things aren't actually happening
raining down fast,
they can fast on dig diver.
He's actually accused of being moving
too fast with see the various people who
accuse him a very things we've seen.
Rosemary is accusing him of something.
Nicole accusing him of something and he's
now being accused by his partner in a
clinic. Um, in,
in this conversation between the France
and his wife for sharing. Cathy said,
you are the solid when you do the
work as the kids are here and toys.
And in my opinion,
the hairs raises almost done.
Friends let themselves believe with ever
increasing conviction that dig travel
intellectually and emotionally at such a
rate of speed that the vibrations Java,
it's only two of them talking behind
his back saying that you know,
that he's not such a great
partner to begin with.
And we see the consequence of that kind
of conversation between France and his
wife. Uh, when they're talking about
they're solving that medical partition,
this is no go. He says suddenly,
well, that's occurred to me.
Praise and that your heart
isn't in this project anymore.
I know I want to leave.
We should strike some arrangement about
taking Nicole's money up gradually.
I thought about that too,
that I've seen this coming.
I'm able to arrange other backing and it
will be possible to take all your money
out by the end of the year to can not
intended to come to decision so quickly.
Nor was he prepare for friends who
sold readily acquiescence in the brake.
You know, he was really without
now without desperation,
he had long felt the ethics
of his profession dissolving
into a lifeless mask.
So this is the speed of the break out of
that and medical practice against again
at the speed that they can not
comment on that he had not asked for.
It is somebody else's being that is
dictated the narrative development.
Um, and they'll just give you, I know
that we're on, was running all the time,
so it gives you the final
part of that resolution, um,
against in fast motion.
You get,
actually I'm going to skip this because
I know that we're running out of time,
so there's this, um, this
will be on the PowerPoint,
but I'm just going to go to the very end
of the narrative about love as war with
spin, seeing the super
imposition of love and we're,
we're one all the way through.
And finally we see the infusion of world
one into this description of Nikos idea
of what the marriage was like.
Again, she struggle with it,
finding him with a small fine eyes with
the pledge arrogance of a top dog within
these and transferring to another man
with a Kimberly with sendlane of years,
she'd fallen with her money and her faith
that his sister just liked him and was
behind her.
Now with a thought of the new enemies
he was making his bitterness for this
other battle she used,
even her weaknesses,
fighting bravely and courageously with
the oak hands and crockery and bottles,
empty receptacles of his
experience, his sins, outrages,
mistakes and sunlight in
the space of two minutes.
She achieved because they train and
justify herself to herself without liars.
Subterfuge cut the court forever.
Okay,
two minutes for her to come to the final
decision about the marriage and this is
the final mirror image.
And this,
I would just say this is a great
moment to pair up with the barber.
Uh,
seeing the rape scene and filmed about
holds the mirror in front of them.
They call reflected the passage between
the man side and the ones and the cost.
Dot it up at the side of Tommy Bob.
And the manager's going to narrate,
entering and willing
sharply into the manager.
She knew of of joy that there was going
to be some kind of showdown in a minute.
They came into Nicole's booth.
His expression in merging and no way
from behind the towel is hastily wins
phase. Your friend has worked
himself up into a state.
He wants to see us together. So I
agree to have it over with. Come along,
but my hair is half cut.
Nevermind. Come along.
Resentfully she understanding coffers,
remove the towels,
filling messy and unadorned.
She followed date from the hotel outside.
Tommy bent over her hand.
We'll go to the cafe that alleys so deep.
So stay in Barbara's.
I've seen the same cutting of the hair
except that in this case the here is only
have cut.
It is the spirit of them resolution.
The marriage is and so hastily that did
hair coloring job is not even completely
done,
but that's the story.
That's the child wants to
delve is hastily done job.